[Inaudible].
What if we took everything that sustains life on this planet
and shrunk it down to one small bubble
earth,
biosphere stretches about 20 kilometers from the deep sea vents in
the ocean, into the atmosphere.
This is where almost all life exists.
If we ever want to live in space or settled Mars,
we will have to recreate this extremely complex system.
What would you eat?
Would you have garbage and what would be the
biggest threat to your health?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you lived in a closed biosphere?
We've tried this once before with disastrous results
in 1991,
eight scientists enclosed themselves in a huge research facility called
biosphere two.
This building was completely shut off from the outside world.
All the food air and water had to be produced and recycled
within its walls. But the experiment quickly began to fail.
There was not enough food or oxygen.
The pollinators died and roaches infested this mini
earth, but could we do it again?
And this time succeed,
the Earth's biosphere is technically a closed system.
The only thing that enters the bias fear is a continuous flow of energy from
the sun,
but creating an earth leg biome is not as easy as it sounds
within Earth's biosphere,
our biomes communities of flora and fauna that occupy major
types of habitats you'd need a collection of biomes to create a
successful life.
Supporting many worlds like biosphere two,
you'd be living in a 12,700 square meter facility,
which would contain a rainforest, an ocean with a coral reef,
mangrove wetlands, Savanna grassland, and a fog desert.
You would also need agricultural land and a place where you lived
and performed laboratory work.
As for your daily routine will be rough.
Keeping yourself alive would be a lot of work.
You spend almost 35% of your time on agriculture.
Then there's all the maintenance lab work and household chores.
Your diet would be mainly vegetarian.
It takes at least 25% more water to produce one kilogram of
meat than one kilogram of wheat,
because animals require a lot of resources.
You carefully select which ones to bring into your bias fear.
I suggest the African pygmy goat,
the most productive domestic animal in biosphere to its milk
would be a welcome break from all the vegetables.
You'd be eating the crew of biosphere.
Two survived mostly on sweet potatoes and beets,
but you do a better job and successfully grow a hundred different
crops, including papaya and rice,
even with all your agricultural work,
starvation would be a real threat because your biome is so
small. The slightest problem can ruin your food crop.
You could have unbalanced soil composition from adding waste,
pollinators, dying off pests, increasing disease.
Whole fields of food could be ruined leaving you very hungry
in the 1991 experiment,
working relentless hours facing constant hunger,
created rifts within the small community to avoid this.
You'd need the perfect number of people to balance the other work and feed
production to few people.
And you'd be overworked too many people,
and there wouldn't be enough food to go around.
Wild crops would be a major focus of your attention.
You'd still need to tend to the rest of the biomes plants.
Wouldn't just be for eating after all.
They'd also produce oxygen and much like the Amazon rainforest
you'd need areas that are full of plant life.
So you could breathe too little oxygen or carbon dioxide,
and you could be in trouble. It's tricky to balance them.
And in biosphere,
two oxygen depletion became a huge issue.
Why they mixed too much organic matter into the soil.
This caused an explosion of oxygen eating microbes,
which decreased the amount of oxygen and the carbon
dioxide produced by these microbes reacted to a chemical in the
biosphere's concrete.
So the plants couldn't use the extra carbon dioxide during
photosynthesis. Luckily we learned from that mistake,
you'd make your biosphere. So it wouldn't react to carbon dioxide.
Okay, so you have enough food and oxygen. That's good,
but what about waste?
It has to go somewhere and there's no room for landfills in your mini world.
You'd have to compost all human and animal waste.
And remember this compost would increase the number of oxygen eating
microbes. So you'd need to plan for that while maintaining your biosphere,
everything you use would be reusable and it would
all have to be compostable.
You'd mend your clothing made out of cotton,
silk and wool many times then you'd use it for rags
then stuffing. And finally, you'd throw it on the compost heap.
You'd rely on technology to circulate air, pump water,
and constantly measure everything in the biosphere.
This takes power and your only options would be solar
nuclear war.
Both earth is a vast complex system where
every living organism, including you and me are connected,
recreating that on any scale is a gargantuan task.
And we'll have to master this process.
If we ever want to settle Mars or create cities on the moon,
want to learn more about living in enclosed biosphere? Join us on.
What if discussed?
We talked with Jane Poynter one of the original eight members of
biosphere. Two. She'll tell us more about the biology,
the oxygen problem,
and the psychology of living in a closed biosphere.